time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week the number
of measles cases in the u.s. continues
to rise now with the most infections
reported since 1994 according to the
most recent data available from the
Centers for Disease Control 700 for
cases of measles have been confirmed in
these first four months of the year that
is nearly double the number of cases
from all of last year here to discuss
this and more CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus good morning
to you please remind us why our measles
so dangerous because maybe that message
needs to come home why millions of
people died before the vaccine there
were several million deaths a year
across the world this vaccine has saved
in the United States millions of lives
and now there are pockets that aren't
being immunized so that number of 700
for the CDC data come out every Monday
so this Monday that needed data will be
dramatically higher you know the vaccine
came out in 1963 but the first years the
vaccine wasn't as potent as it is today
and so people born from 1963 to 1968 may
need a second booster that includes the
two of us Anthony I'm on the list and it
was until 1989 that we gave the two
shots that confers pretty amazing
immunity and with that I mean children
are supposed to get those two shots for
the MMR vaccine but if you're an adult
should you be thinking about getting
another vaccination if you're not sure
if you've even gotten those first two
the answer is yes if you're born before
1957 you don't because everyone got
measles then but after that if you don't
none of us have our vaccine records
we're not sure if we got the good
vaccine at big mixing you could get a
blood test that tells you how your
vaccine is but the bottom line is the
vaccine is probably cheaper and there's
little downside to getting a booster of
the vaccine you know we don't give it to
kids till age 12 months so I know
parents that are afraid to go out now in
New York City in the subway because
they're afraid someone will call on them
and they'll bring it home to their
newborn and give them measles it's a
scary time a lot of those cases were in
New York out of the 700 plus many of
them are yeah we blame New York for a
lot of things it's our fault
David so which of that what should
Public Health Services take away from
this
like in cases what they what do they
learn from this I think this is a
watershed moment is that we really have
to push to vaccinate children not just
for the child but for the community
we're all living together and we have to
take care of each other it's like
secondhand smoke
you know you affect other people and
that's what got people to stop smoking
my hope is this is what really brings up
vaccination rates too we're all
protected next up electric scooters
they're becoming increasingly popular in
cities around the country what's less
well known is how many bumps and bruises
and even more serious injuries they're
causing for their riders the Austin
Texas Department of Public Health with
the assistance of the CDC launched a
study to examine the public health
impact of scooters what did they find
David it's an amazing study I mean to me
it's amazing because about 1/3 of the
people who had injuries it was the first
time riding a scooter 2/3 they'd only
driven it a few times so what that means
is we're not educating people well
there's a video you're supposed to watch
how many of us look at the introductory
thing is reduce clamors watch the video
first of all we need to educate better
and in that study only one person was
wearing a helmet Oh wear your helmet I
mean that that's a given but what about
that education what can riders do to be
safer what the scooters are great right
in that you know there's no emissions
you know get people out of cars you're
out of doors I mean they're all over Los
Angeles where I live but we need to do
it safely and you need to do it with a
helmet you need to do it in the right
lane and you know they go up to 15 miles
an hour so they ain't slow so we may
need to temper down the speed a little
but I think it's gonna be great for
community and for transportation and
cities going forward all right finally
building blocks for building skills Lego
recently announced support for project
to help blind and visually impaired
children learn Braille in a unique way
the textured knobs at the top of the
Lego bricks will act as Braille dots and
will also feature a printed letter or
character so both visually impaired and
sighted children can both play the Lego
bricks are currently being tested in
multiple languages and the final Lego
Braille kit is expected to be available
sometime next year I love this it's
amazing it hasn't happened till now but
it is brilliant we have to bring back
Braille apparently you know people
aren't learning Braille anymore and we
have audiobooks right yep good books
Mader yeah based on that article I think
they said ten percent of children in
this country who are visually impaired
know how to read Braille only ten
percent well kids need to read yeah kids
love Legos so that's a good one all
right thank you dr. agus